if you think people work for you as the
CEO or the founder of a company versus
you working for them you will never ever
ever ever ever ever ever
zoom in ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever
build a good culture in a company what's
your advice on uh building a great
culture in your company
I've got a lot on this and and honestly
this is probably the place where I can
see myself going more and more because
soon vayner's really really really going
to be big and it's going to be really
because of this and then I'll feel
confident that I'm allowed to talk about
it I've started talking about a little
bit because we're starting to get big
are you the partner CEOs like is it your
business yeah
first and foremost you have to realize
in a real way in a non-bullshit way that
you work for them if you do not do that
you've lost
if you think people work for you as the
CEO or the founder of a company versus
you working for them you will never ever
ever ever ever ever ever
zoom in ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever
build a good culture in a company that
is number one got it
number two
you have to realize that there is no
blanket rules
everybody in your company how many
employees you have uh 330 330. great
nice number you have to micromanage 330
people's wants Ambitions and needs on an
everyday basis predicate on what else is
happening in their lives day after day
month after month year after year what
that means is he may be motivated by
money I love when people like
Millennials are so Zen and I'm
Millennials who literally rather work an
extra 20 hours for six more bucks and
you know so like you have to figure out
what drives them is it money
is it work-life balance like are they a
huge you know Chelsea fan and you buy
them random tickets when they aren't
looking and then they're like oh my God
you actually know something about me you
think I pay attention a lot to you guys
I [__] stalk the [__] out of my 650
employees on social media
I know who [__] loves Tinder
I know who loves bourbon
I know it all
and so it's very hard to scale
one-on-one context with 330 employees
the other thing is you have to build
infrastructure last Friday I announced a
new role that I announced was the most
senior role in the company besides me
more senior than AJ more senior than
James Orsini my right hand guy more
senior than my CFO who is Claude silver
who is now my partner basically in the
company and she's the chief heart
officer
um she will help me scale the mapping of
one to one because you know Rick who
wants money at 22 to 24 might want
something else when he gets engaged
because his partner wants him home on
the weekends and he used to want to work
and make money and so he would work on
Saturday and now he doesn't want to or
scaring your [__] that I'm always
mentally prepared for which is a tragedy
may happen in your family and you have
to leave for nine months and you come
back shaken and so the only way
to build great culture is not only
through words that are written on the
wall
but in your actions
you have to make every one of those
people understand that you care more
about them than you want them to care
about you it is the only one and
and
I swear I'm trying to do it at a level
that's never been done before but
wherever I land
is what I will have if I'm a 92 and the
Market's a 67 that's incredible right
you can't be crippled by the task what I
just said some people get crippled when
I tell them that advice on 13 employees
you got 3 30 my man I got 650 like it's
tough but if you do it you will build
great culture and if you don't every
step of the way that you do less of it
you will have less of that culture thank
you you got it and
and it's about allocating the dollars to
the right things one of the best things
I do is the most talented people in my
company if they are not bought into
being the bigger woman and bigger man in
every situation I don't care if they're
the number one sales person the best
creative director they're
right and you have to be religious about
that the second you let somebody get
away with something you will lose and
the meritocracy we started the company
with eight of AJ's friends some of them
are the number 10 most important and
well-compensated employee and some of
them are number 387 meritocracy
if you take care of your nephew better
than somebody's hustling you've died
you're done your culture's broke you let
something besides meritocracy rule
[Music]